Let's get started.
We'll cut right to the chase.
How did it go on the exam?
I crushed that.
I heard I crushed that.
Yeah.
Look at that.
So you guys rocked it on exam
one, and I'm very proud of you,
and I think this is awesome.
The average was actually
really high, which is great.
It means, to me, that you guys
have learned the materials
that we want you to learn in
the first third of this class.
You know, this is also a chance
that if you didn't get up
into this range, you're
here or down here,
or even if you're
up here, and there
are a couple of problems
you didn't quite get,
this is the time to go back
and say, what did I miss?
Right.
How did I misinterpret?
Or what did I miss, and
go back over it now.
Solidify this knowledge.
Why?
Because of what's coming next.
And I really want
to contextualize
this with something
really important to me.
And that's bread.
Now, if you want to get the best
ride in town you go to Bricco.
All right, and I really
actually strongly
encourage you all to go to
Bricco, because it's true.
It's really the
best bread in town.
There's Frank.
He founded Bricco.
It's in the South end.
It's amazing.
But you notice his
ingredients, there's
only seven ingredients
in the bread at Bricco.
There's salt,
right, yeast, water.
There.
Anybody know what farina is?
Flour.
OK, crusca, it's like
kind of wheat stuff.
Oil and passione.
Passione.
Passion.
It's the thing he's holding.
That's ingredient number
seven at Bricco, which
is the best friend in town.
Now, here's my point.
I need you guys to keep bringing
the passion to this class.
You should be bringing
the passion to everything
you do, because that's
what we do at MIT, right?
That's how we approach
everything we do.
But I need you not to say, well,
I did really well in exam one,
and now I can kind
of phone it in.
That's not the time to do it.
Trust me.
Because now we're going into
the next phase, the next third,
a little bit less than a
third of the class where
we're going to come maybe out
of some of our comfort zones.
All right.
So some of you have seen
a lot of the material
that we've already covered.
Some of you haven't.
And some of you
may have seen some
of the material
we're about to cover
in the next week or
two, shapes of molecules
and molecular orbital
theory, hybridization.
But then we're going
to go into crystals,
and we're going to take
molecular orbitals,
and we're going to
make solid orbitals out
of them, which are called
bands, which is going
to give us semiconductors.
And then we're going to
dope those with chemistry.
All sorts of stuff.
So keep up the passion, please.
That's why I was showing
you Frank and Bricco.
Keep up the passion.
OK, now today, we're going to
cover a really important follow
up to Lewis, which
is, how to predict
what shape a molecule will be.
And so, you know, if I take,
so for example, H2Be and H20,
now those look--
right, OK, so, H Be H and
H O H, right, from Lewis,
we don't really know why
they both looked that way.
Are they both linear?
Are the ones below both linear?
How do we tell what
shape they are?
And as I'll tell
you about today,
so I'm going to give you
a way to do that and then
a recipe, another
recipe, just like Lewis,
and then, we're going to talk
about the goody bag, which
allows you to touch
and feel the shapes.
You can't-- we're
going beyond 2D.
We're coming out of the board.
We're going 3D.
You got to hold it in your hand.
Now, unfortunately, we
couldn't buy like 500 kits
that are this big.
But I'll pass these around,
because you can just
feel-- in these
molecules, you can just
feel that if I do this,
it's a different molecule.
If I rotate that, it's
a different molecule.
It's actually going to
have different properties.
And so that's what
we learned today.
Lewis, this is just all
flattened into the board.
Doesn't tell me enough.
It doesn't tell-- I need
to know what those--
is it like that?
I don't know.
Do the yellow things
want to be that close,
or should it maybe be
like that or like that?
You see how when
you can do this?
I could do this
for hours honestly.
So I'll pass these around.
And I'm certain at
some point we're
going to hear loud clinking
sounds of these balls falling
apart.
They're not held
together too well.
Please try to not--
just play with it a little bit.
Right, and then your kit is
a smaller version of that.
OK, so how do we do this?
How do I tell you what
shape that should be?
Well, we have a way to do
this, and it's got a name even.
So just to contrast,
Lewis is what we did last.
And Lewis gives me the
numbers and type of bonds, OK.
The number and type of bonds.
But now, I've got
a way that's called
Valence-Shell Electron-Pair
Repulsion model, VSEPR, VSEPR.
But see, chemists are--
if I haven't conveyed this
before, chemists are really
good at naming things.
So it could be valence electron
shell pair repulsion model.
It's not.
But it could be.
And if it weren't
we'd call it VESPR.
It would sound a lot better.
Right, and so that's
what we call it
even though we write VSEPR.
So we write it like
this, but we say vesper,
because this is chemistry.
And this gives us the shape.
Now, it's based on actually a
very straightforward premise,
which is that electrons repel
each other, something we
already knew.
OK, electrons repel each other,
and the stable arrangement--
I hear that molecule
changing shape.
It makes me happy.
OK, the stable
arrangement minimizes--
now, this makes sense right?
Minimizes the repulsions.
OK, that's really the
whole premise of VSEPR.
VSEPR theory is a way--
it's a very simple recipe
that we will learn and apply
that is based on this premise.
We already talked
about electrons
repelling each other in
atoms, right, and in a bond.
And now we use the same
idea that electrons
repel each other for a molecule,
right, within a molecule.
OK, good.
But we need to rank order this.
We need to rank order this.
And so we have a rank order.
And you'll see kind
of why, as we go.
I'll tell it to you right now.
And I need
abbreviations, because I
don't want to keep writing
bonding pair and lone pair.
So I'm going to say that a
bonding pair, a bonding pair,
oh what's a bonding pair?
Well, it's the two electrons
in a bond right there.
That's a bonding pair.
OK, good.
So a bonding pair, to save time,
we're going to write as a BP.
And a lone pair,
what's a long pair?
Well, we already know that.
A lone pair is right there.
A non-bonding pair,
a lone pair, an LP.
OK, good.
Now, this allows me, now that
I have this very important key,
I can tell you
what the repulsion
order is without writing out
bonding and lone all the time.
Repulsion order and this
is what we follow in VSEPR.
OK, so we're going to go the
lowest repulsion is between two
bonding pairs, bonding
pair to bonding pair.
And the medium medium, OK,
so the next in our list
is bonding pair to lone
pair, and the highest
is between two lone pairs.
All I'm telling you
is in this ordering
is that OK, electrons repel
each other, yeah, got it,
but there's an ordering to it.
If I'm a lone pair, and
I see another lone pair,
that I'm more repelled.
Those two things are
more repelled, then
a lone pair and a
bonding pair, which
are more repelled than
two bonding pairs,
and we got one more thing
we got to think about,
because you see the bonding
pairs can be single, double,
or triple.
And so those have a
rank order, which also
makes a lot of sense, right.
So like one bonding pair
would have a single bond.
With a single bond would
have a lower repulsion
than a double bond, which
would have less repulsion
than a triple bond, right?
But that makes a
lot of sense, right?
You're putting more
electrons in the bond.
And so there's more
stuff to repel.
Right, so if I'm talking
about bonding pairs,
there is also a sub order.
OK, that makes sense, right?
So this is like a single bond
line, two lines, no room,
three lines, right?
All right.
Now this frames the VSEPR model.
Now let's apply it, and
the rules are actually
really pretty straightforward.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to build our
understanding by applying this
to some examples, because
it's exactly the same thing we
did with Lewis.
OK, so I'm going to start my
recipe with the first three
ingredients.
Passion is always there, too.
But these are the first three
ingredients of my VSEPR recipe.
First, I write the structure.
We know how to do that.
We learn how to do that.
And then I'm going to classify
the pairs of electrons
as bonding or non-bonding.
So I'm going to just
label them like that.
And then I'm going to maximize
the separation between domains
and pay attention
to these rules,
and I'm going to
start a little bit
of a table over here, number--
because we're going to fill
this table out-- number
of electron regions.
OK, let's do this.
You know when I do this,
there's nothing but fun coming.
Nothing but fun.
I went all the way,
all the way over.
Why?
Because I need some space.
Now, here, we're going to
say electron pair geometry.
We'll be talking about
this today, geometry.
OK, good.
And then, here, OK, now this
is sort of the molecular--
molecular geometry.
So I'm going from--
I'm going from counting
electron regions
and labeling what kind they are
to a geometry of the electron
cloud around things to an
actual molecular shape, which
is what VSEPR gives us, and to
know why is this so wide, well,
because there's options in here.
Right, because I could
have no lone pairs.
All right.
I could have one lone pair.
And this will all
make a lot of sense.
Two lone pairs and so on.
We'll keep going
as we get there.
OK, so I'm going to start
with a very simple case.
I'm going to start with this.
Right.
And then we're going to put some
stuff into that table as we go.
All right.
So look if I have H, Be H,
then that's already 0.1.
I'm going to write, just
like I did with Lewis,
I'm going to write the
number of the recipe
next to what I'm
doing on the board.
OK, so one, write
Lewis structure.
I did it.
OK, good.
Now two, I've got
two electron pairs.
OK, and they're both bonding.
Both are BP.
OK, and so I've
got two BP domains.
And as you can see,
I've got no LP domains.
And so three, this is
going to be max separation,
max sep will have to be linear.
There's just no
other way about it.
I've only got two
electron domains.
I've got no lone pairs.
So two bonding domains,
two electron domains.
It's got to be linear.
That's the only way I can go.
So if the number of
electron regions is two,
which it is for BeH2, OK,
and and then the number of--
the electron pair
geometry is linear, right,
because that maximizes
the separations.
And there is no lone
pairs, and so it's linear.
You say, well, that
really seems redundant.
It is in this case.
It's not going to stay that
way, not going to stay that way.
OK.
Good.
One lone pair, no.
No lone pairs.
I mean, if I had two
electron regions total, OK,
and one of them was a lone
pair, it's kind of boring.
I mean, you know, if this
were a lone pair here,
instead of a bond, well,
clearly it's linear.
There's only two atoms.
That's kind of
the simplest case.
We won't really talk about that.
Good.
OK, now it's the
same kind of thing.
Let me just make sure that
there's no confusion here.
And let's not leave this up.
But if I had--
let's say I go back to
my first slide there.
OK, so what if I had this one.
It looks more complicated.
Right, it looks
more complicated.
So now, OK, so OK, step one O
and here you go, here you go.
And there's a point
I want to make here,
because if I count
up the bonding pair
domains and the lone
pair domains on this one,
all right, say well, OK, I've
got the bonding pairs here.
I've got some BPs.
I've got two BP domains right?
Here and here, just
like I did in H Be H.
But oh, I've got all
these lone pairs now.
Don't I have four lone pairs?
No.
And the reason is we
have to pick an atom.
In VSEPR, we have
to pick an atom.
We're doing this around an atom.
VSEPR applies around an atom.
You pick a central, and I picked
carbon as my central atom.
And then you apply VSEPR.
So there's no lone
pairs around the carbon.
That doesn't matter for
the shape around carbon.
OK, that's really important.
So I pick my central atom.
So now I know there's
no lone pairs, no LP,
because central atom.
You know what I
mean, central atom.
And then finally,
three, we're going
to get linear because,
again, there's
only two electron domains.
There's going to
electron domains,
and the only geometry really
that you can take in this case
is linear.
No lone pairs, two
electron domains.
Good.
And now you know it's
about to get fun,
because now we're going
to go to something more.
Let's go back to our recipe.
There it is.
OK, so I'm going to make
room here and do my next one.
I'm going to go a little
bit more complicated.
So now I've got BF3.
So B, and we're
going to go F, F, F.
And we know we got all these
lone pairs out on the F's.
Remember this is one
that's electron deficient.
We talked about this last
week, electron deficient.
So the boron is happy
even though it's only
got those three bonds.
The question is,
what's the shape?
We've been drawing these
structures like this in 2D.
What's the real shape?
Now we can apply VSEPR
because that's step one.
Step two is that I've got three
bonding pairs, 3 BP, right,
and no LP.
OK.
And so now if I have
three electron domains,
three electron domains, which
I have, then the max separation
for this case, max sep is going
to be for them to spread out
in a trigonal plane.
OK, so that's what
they're going to do.
And that is called
trigonal planar.
It has a name trigonal planar.
So you know, it's kind of--
planar.
So it's kind of right,
but it's not quite right
because I drew with
90 degree angles,
and that's not what
they are going to do
to maximize their spacing here.
They're going to go
at angles like that.
All right, they're
going to find 120.
So if I have three electron
regions, here we go, then--
now I had three--
OK, so the electron
pair geometry.
Why is this different?
You will see in a minute.
The electron pair geometry
covers BPs and LPs,
but in this case,
there's only BPs.
Fine.
There's still only three.
Right, and so it's
trigonal planar.
Trigonal planar.
And guess what, if
there is no LPs--
OK, so the structure
that the molecule takes
or those electron domains
takes is trigonal planar.
The structure that the molecule
takes if there is no LPs
is also trigonal planar.
But now, the moment
we've been waiting for
is what happens when
that's not true,
and you've got a lone pair.
So again, we're going
to do this by example.
OK, and so my next
example is formaldehyde,
which is something we love to
talk about when we did Lewis.
So CH2O.
OK, so the Lewis structure
for this looks like this.
Right, we drew this before,
O, it's got the lone pairs out
here, and then there's H and
another H. That's formaldehyde.
OK, now hold on.
But there's no-- are
there any lone pairs here?
There's no lone pairs.
So hold on.
If I go to two, I've
got three bonding pairs
and zero lone pairs.
It looks a whole lot like
BF3, but it's different.
It's different, because
now this matters.
Now this matters.
Right, and so now--
so now, I've got to add--
so it's like-- so 3 would
give you trigonal planar.
Right, 3 gives you
trigonal planar,
because I've only got
those three domains,
but now I need four.
And there's four.
You knew there was
something else, right?
Give more space to
non-bonding domains
and to bonding domains
with higher bond order.
That's the fourth
part of the recipe.
This just goes with
what I wrote here.
Right, so I've got
differences in the molecule
between the BPs.
So you know now that I
got to give more space
to this double bond
single bond repulsion
than to these two single bonds.
All right.
So step four for this case
is that the bond order
is important.
And this molecule will bend.
So the shape of the molecule
is going to be bent.
It will bend, because this--
I didn't draw it this way.
If I wanted to be right about
it, I'm going to go like this,
still not quite right.
Right, and this repulsion is
stronger than that repulsion.
It bends the shape.
So it's not trigonal planar.
The electron domains give you
a trigonal planar framework,
but the molecule itself is bent.
OK.
And there's another example
of that that we could do.
There's another example of that,
and that is-- let's do it here.
And that is if we had
the lone pair, which
is what I mentioned before.
So I'm going to take another
example here, which is SO2.
And in this case, uh-oh.
Am I making a mistake?
I can hear--
I can hear stuff.
Did I make a mistake?
No.
I see this.
I did.
I do, and that's wrong.
Bond order is important, but
it is not under one lone pair.
It is not under one lone pair.
It would be under here.
And it would be-- if
there is a bond order,
it would be best if bond order.
Sorry about that.
Bond O. Trigonal planar,
trigonal planar, slightly bent.
Look at this.
I should have just kept this.
Bent, bent, because
now, I've got--
look at this.
In this Lewis structure,
I've got two BP and one LP.
And finally, we have the
case of the lone pair,
and we can fill this
column in, and it's bent.
And it's bent because,
again, it's the same.
I go back to this as my key.
OK, so I did bone
pair, bond pair,
but there was a slight
shape difference
because of the ordering
of the bond pairs.
Here, it's going to be
even higher because I've
got a lone pair.
Actually it's a lone
pair double bond,
but it's still stronger than a
bond pair bond pair repulsion.
Lone pair bond pair,
right in the middle
is stronger than
bond pair bond pair.
That's the rank order.
So this will be bent.
This will be bent.
So I've got three
domains, and hold on,
four LP more repulsive.
Oh boy, repulsive, and
so that gives me bent.
Trigonal planar,
trigonal planar, bent.
OK.
Did I get through that
without making more mistakes?
So we're going to go
further than this, which is
why this is only the beginning.
But before I do, why
does shape matter?
I told you shape mattered
in the very beginning,
but why does it matter?
Isn't it just important to
know what the chemistry is
and not the actual shape?
Why does the shape matter?
And so I thought
I would give you
an example of that with smell.
And yeah, right?
Exactly.
And actually, I think we
should do this more often.
You know, I feel like
this is inspiring.
We talk about stopping
and smelling the flowers,
but do we actually do it?
And look at that.
They've got one arm
around the other.
This is a moment.
You can't share this
moment on Instagram.
You have to put your
phone down and be
there to have this moment.
And I highly encourage you
to be inspired by this.
Now, smell and taste
are actually related.
And smell is, you know, it's
actually a fascinating thing.
We can smell about
10,000 different smells.
It's remarkable.
A dog can smell between
10 and 100,000 times more.
Right, so if you do the analogy
that people do with vision,
we can see a third of a mile.
A dog can see about 3,000 miles.
Right, that's pretty cool.
But the question
is why do we smell?
How do we smell?
How do we taste?
And it turns out that the
way that we distinguish
from one smell and
one taste and another
has to do with the
shape of the molecule.
And so just like a
key right, with a key,
it's all of the same material.
It's the same
chemistry in the key.
But the shape is different that
can unlock the door or not.
That is literally how
our receptor cells
work for taste and smell.
This is a cartoon I found
that I kind of like.
See, OK, shapes,
circles, squares, right.
OK, and some shapes come in, and
they make happiness, happiness,
flowers and stuff.
I don't know.
Is cheese happy?
It looks neutral.
I would get happy with cheese.
But anyway, fish
for some reason,
but you know, it depends.
But it's shape dependent.
Now the thing is, taste
works that way, too.
So this is what's
happening in your tongue.
You've got these taste buds.
We've all heard the
word taste bud, right?
But what is really going on?
What is really going on is
a combination of chemistry
and shape recognition.
So the taste bud, if you
look at the taste bud,
that's inside of the little
pores inside your tongue.
There's a blow up of it.
And so this is what the surface
of your tongue looks like.
And there's a little pore.
And there's little
filters in there
that helps certain molecules
kind of get in there.
And what happens when
they get in there.
Well, what happens is you've got
these taste receptor cells that
are like lock key pairs.
They actually only look at
like the circle or the diamond,
and they can tell you
which one is which.
And that's a major part of how
we distinguish from one shape
to another, and
it's actually so--
it goes back a long way.
Why?
Because shape and smell
are literally survival.
They are literally
like you can--
if you taste something, and it
tastes poisonous, don't eat it.
You live.
Right?
So it is a very emotional
thing to smell and taste,
because it is actually
coupled to your very survival.
And Democritus
himself, Democritus,
our friend Democritus, said
that shape must be involved.
He thought that because
things that taste bitter
are sharp that the bitter
molecules were sharp.
They must have sharpness to
them, like shards of glass.
That's how he imagined.
And the sweet
molecules were sort
of the soft, fluffy spheres.
That's not that far
off from being sort
of what happens a little bit.
But when we look at it like,
you know, glucose and quinine,
we say, OK, those are very
different chemistries.
So it might not be as
obvious why one of them
taste so different
than the other.
But check out this example.
This is the same molecule,
the carvone molecule
that is called an
enantiomer, which
means that it has handedness.
It's the exact same
chemical formula
and the exact same structure,
except for one is like this,
and one is like that.
That's handedness.
Right.
And that difference
makes one of them
taste and smell like spearmint
and the other like caraway
seeds, right?
It's incredible.
It means that in our
tongues in our noses
we must have chiral, the ability
to determine the chirality.
It's pretty cool.
Right.
So shape is critical, and
this is one example of why.
This is one example of why.
OK.
Back to my VSEPR recipe.
Now, we've got to go a
little further, because this
is three electron domains,
three electron domains.
They can be messed around.
Right, especially
in this table, we're
talking about lone pairs or not.
OK, I gave you the example,
which I kind of fudged
in there with bond order.
But what happens
if I go to four?
So if I go to four, let's
do an example with four--
if I go to four, I
need some room here.
Why don't I do it
in the center here?
Let's do an example
of all possibilities
with four, with four domains.
And there's three really
good examples, right?
And you know them.
Let's do CH4.
So we'll do these kind
of more quickly, CH4--
gesundheit-- which will be CH--
never leave enough room on top.
And H. There it is.
OK.
Anyway.
And NH3.
OK, so N H H H. And
H20 to all O H H. This
is how I drew it
on the first slide.
Or this is how I drew
it up there before.
Now the thing is that in
each of these cases, what
I want you to see in
these three examples is
their similarity first.
And their similarity is that if
I pick my central atom, carbon,
nitrogen, oxygen, if I
pick my central atom,
and I look around it, each
one has four electron domains.
Right.
So in this sense, the kind of
overarching electron geometry
is identical for all
three of those cases.
It's identical.
And it's tetrahedral,
tetrahedral.
OK, that's the
electron pair geometry
that's exactly the same.
But I need to now count--
oh, there's the recipe.
I need to now classify
the electron pair
as bonding or
non-bonding and then
maximize the separation
between domains
while giving more space to
non-bonding domains and bonding
domains with higher bond order
as we have now talked about.
So if I do that, here, what
I have is four bonding pairs,
zero, zero lone pairs.
Here, I've got three bonding
pairs, one lone pair.
And now I really get to
fill in stuff in my table,
because now, I've got the
examples of zero, one,
and two lone pairs for the
same electron domain cloud.
OK, so there is
zero, one, and two.
You can see in methane,
OK, the only way for this
to maximize its repulsion,
they're all the same bonding
pair, they're all single
bonds, so there's not
going to be any kind
of funny business
of a double bond pushing harder,
and there's no lone pairs.
And so this is just going to
have the tetrahedral shape.
That will be the
shape of the molecule.
That is the electron
domain shape as well.
So in this case, it will be
tetrahedral, tetrahedral.
OK, but see, now,
in this case, I've
got three bonding pairs
and one lone pair,
and we know because of the
VSEPR recipe, which has--
oh, it's up there.
I keep forgetting it's up there.
OK we know that I want to
maximize the separation,
but I got to give more
space to the non-bonding,
because the lone pair bond
repulsion is stronger.
Good.
So what that means is it's going
to be sort of like tetrahedral,
but in one place,
there is no bond.
There's just this lone
pair pushing down.
And so the shape that
you're going to get
is called trigonal,
trigonal pyramidal.
OK, because now, that's just
the way that shape looks.
So this is going to--
I'll show you actually a
picture of this in a second,
OK, of what this looks like.
And then with water, we
now know that this will not
be the most stable
configuration,
because these lone pairs
are pushing on these bonds
too much, so water
is actually going
to look like this, where
these guys, the lone pairs
can come out like that, right,
that angles like that, be away
from each other, right, and
then the bonds are down there,
and that's going to maximize
the shape of the water--
I mean, it's going to
minimize the repulsions
that the electrons
feel in the water.
And that is back to the
same name, which is bent.
I've got a different
number of electron domains,
but I wind up with the
same molecular shape.
See that?
Bent.
Now, I know this
is kind of small.
I've got tables that
have all this at the end
that you'll have in the slides.
OK, so I know this is a
little bit crammed in here,
but the process
of writing this is
very, very fun and fulfilling.
Now, we can keep going.
But I want to tell you about
a labeling system that's
actually really helpful.
So if we keep going,
we kind of want
a system to be able to
think about these things.
And so there is a system.
Again, this is chemistry.
We know how to name things.
Oh, but I promised you
I'd show you that first.
So here it is.
There it is.
I didn't know why.
I click to that already.
That's this.
And the reason I wanted to
show you this, this is from
[? Avril, ?] your
textbook that you're all
reading so carefully.
And look at that.
This really brings it home.
Look at that lone pair.
Now you're seeing
it as the electrons
feel it, which is a
probability distribution cloud.
That's the lone
pair, and now you
can see the lone
pair wants space.
It wants room, and
it's pushing down
on these bonds, which are
pushing away from each other.
And that's how
you can figure out
what shape it is,
trigonal pyramidal.
That's trigonal pyramidal,
OK, the molecule.
Right, as I said, we need a way
to label things in chemistry.
So we can keep going-- linear,
trigonal planar, tetrahedral,
trigonal bipyramidal, oh,
five, octahedral, six.
Don't get confused octa,
eight, but octahedral
is for six electron
pair domains, right.
But we need a
system to name this.
And so the chemists have
brilliantly come up with AXE.
Now A is the central atom.
X is the bonding pair regions,
and E is the lone pair regions.
X and E. OK, and so if
I go back to like BF3,
well, this would be--
oh there you go, AX3.
I say, what is the shape of AX3?
I know I've got to
central atom, A,
and I've got three bonding pairs
around it and no lone pairs.
That's what that means.
I could go back as SO2.
Where is SO2?
Did I erase it?
Maybe I erased SO2.
I did erase SO2.
Oh, I didn't erase SO2.
Happiness.
Look at this.
SO2 would be AX2E.
Or if you want, you
can put a 1 there.
It's a highly sophisticated,
advanced labeling system.
That simply allows
us to keep going,
to keep going without
writing so many words.
But we know now, A
is the central atom.
X is the number of
bonding pair regions.
E is the number of
lone pair regions.
And we know about our rules,
and we know about bond order.
So now if I look at those same--
really?
What happened to-- oh,
there they are up there.
If I look at those
same ones, well, OK,
look those are tetrahedral.
OK, the electron
pair distribution
is tetrahedral,
but-- gesundheit.
But as you can see
in these pictures,
you can get three
different molecular shapes.
You can get tetrahedral,
same as the electron pair.
You can get trigonal
pyramidal, or you can get bent.
Those are the names
of the molecule.
Notice that those
aren't the names that
include the lone pairs.
Lone pairs are how you find
which one of these categories
you're in.
But those are the
names of the molecules.
Those are really
important, those
names of the molecular shape.
Now, if I move over one--
OK, oh there they are,
names, tetrahedral, trigonal,
pyramidal, bent.
Now, let's move over one.
So now I'm going to stop.
I'm not going to keep on
writing everything down.
Let's see one last example.
So here's trigonal bipyramidal.
This is what happens when
you have five electron pair
domains.
Again, and I keep
saying this, but I
know that this can lead
to confusion later.
So I keep on reiterating,
the electron payer domain
count, right, the five here,
the five here, which gives us
this overall kind of electron
payer domain shape, that
would be five there, right,
trigonal bipyramidal,
that includes a single, double,
or triple bond is a domain.
It's a BP.
Right, it's a BP domain.
A lone pair is a domain.
How many of those do you have
floating around your molecule,
around your atom?
Sorry, your central atom.
And then you go down and
you sort of decompose it
in terms of how many of them are
bonding pairs, X's, versus how
many of them are lone pairs.
So let's do one last example.
And it'll be for five.
It'll be for five,
right, so five.
And I want you to really--
I'll go with the center again.
I want you to really kind of get
a feeling for why this works.
And this is, I think,
a nice example.
If you had the molecule, if
you had the molecule SF4,
I'll give you two
examples today that
violate the octet rule,
right, because chemistry
lives in the fast lane.
If you have SF4, S is willing
to have an expanded octet,
all right.
As you go down in
the periodic table,
atoms are more willing
to live in the fast lane
and break the rules.
S-- we've drawn it like
this, F, F, F, all right,
we've drawn it like
this, violating
the octet rule and
all that, but still
being happy because
it's lowest in energy.
And these are all my
electron non-binding domains.
OK.
If I count-- remember, those
aren't going to matter.
They're on the outside.
I'm picking one atom.
A is S. Right, A
is S in this case.
And in this case, I've got--
you know, I've got, OK,
how many body pairs?
I've got four bonding
pairs and one lone pair,
and one lone pair.
And so you can see--
I can just look
this up here AX4E1.
It must be a seesaw structure.
But I want you to
see it, and this
is where playing with these
models really helps you see it.
Because if you think about
this, it seems, at first,
that if I had four bonding
pairs and one lone pair,
why can't I just
write it like this?
This seems like a good
idea at first, right?
S, and then you've got
a fluorine down here.
And then you're going to go out.
I'm using a kind of
cool new notation here.
Right-- and then
you're going to go.
Did somebody just say whoa?
Or is that just in my mind?
Like that, but I'm saying whoa.
That's a terrible
rendition of this notation.
But this means-- now I've
got to come on the board.
And for me, that's
challenging because I'm not
very good at drawing 3D things.
And so we use these little
shaded in kind of sticks
like that, and it
comes out of the board,
and then that's
like the dashed one,
and it goes into the board.
So there's one--
that looks terrible.
I'm going to try one more time.
So maybe if I just do
this, F, F. And this
is in the same plane here.
These three are in a plane,
and that's going down.
And you've got your
lone pair up here.
That looks pretty good.
Why is that better than
something like this?
And now, one coming out of
the board and the other going
into the board, all right, and
now this would be-- gesundheit.
This would be my
other possibility.
I mean, if I think
about, I think
why can't it just be this?
These look-- I don't know.
These look nice and spread out.
Why not?
It's the lone pair again.
It's the lone pair.
It's got to be,
because, you know,
I put up there, somewhere,
there's not there,
that the lone pair
repels the bonds more,
and I've got more than
say a bond and a bond.
But the point is I've
got three of those here.
This has three,
one, two, and three.
This has two.
This is a happier structure.
Right.
So I wanted you to see-- so this
is the way to think about it.
You're using VSEPR.
You're applying
these principles.
I mean, it's just a
four-point recipe,
but I'm hoping that in
thinking about it this way
and having the little
models in your hand,
which you have in
this goody bag,
that you guys will also kind
of have a feeling for it,
so that yes, you
have the tables that
are written out much better
than how I wrote them out.
And here's one in the lecture
notes that I'll leave you,
right, total domains.
It's very similar, notation,
structures, OK, shapes.
But also that you have a feeling
for why this is the case.
All right, shapes of molecules.
See you guys on
Wednesday-- no, Friday.